(fire alarm ringing)
- [Ramona] Every day,
whenever I hear that buzzer,
it just gets your blood flowing,
your heart pumping,
and you just take off at a sprint.
(propellers whirring)
You really don't know
what your getting into
until you can see the fire.
(man mumbling on headset)
You're jumping out of a plane.
That's always gonna induce
a little bit of adrenaline.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] There are few professions
that captivate us quite like smokejumping,
and I'm speaking with a
woman who has been doing it
for over a decade.
- [Ramona] My name is Ramona Beyuka,
and I am a McCall
smokejumper in McCall, Idaho.
- [Narrator] She jumps out of planes
and into forest fires.
Her job is to contain them.
This is what a day for
a smokejumper is like.
(dramatic music)
- [Ramona] You fly in a Twin
Otter, with the door off.
We're all wearing ear plugs,
and everyone's kind of in
their own world at that point.
- [Narrator] And this flight
can take up to a few hours.
But it becomes clear when they're close.
- [Ramona] Usually, you smell that smoke.
If it's that tiny, wood-burning smell,
you know that it's go time.
You get in the door,
and that's when you really gotta focus.
(woman exhales slowly)
Your heart is pounding,
and then they slap you on your shoulder.
I don't even really think about it.
I just go out of the plane.
(electronic alarm blaring)
(heart pounding)
I try not look at the ground,
or the fire, at that point.
You're just super-focused.
(electronic alarm blaring)
(heart pounding)
- [Narrator] And that was just part one.
Now they fight the fire.
(airplane propellers whirring)
(fire crackling)
- [Ramona] I've been to
so many forest fires,
and yet every jump is different.
- [Narrator] But it's not
a profession for everyone.
- [Ramona] That adrenaline is something
that's a big part of
keeping me coming back.
I do stop and think,
"Wow, I am really lucky
to be in this job."
(dramatic music)